this is why people take Addy the
perspective is that like oh I feel good
I feel focused I only took it one time
and it was a very very very small amount
everyone knew like you probably
shouldn't be taking massive amounts of
Adderall at a land but people were doing
it awk was quoted saying if you are not
taking Adderall then you are putting
yourself at an intentional disadvantage
for years Adderall has been a touchy
subject in Esports for those unfamiliar
with the drug Adderall is a stimulant
designed to give your focus energy
levels and other important things a
boost which is why despite being a
prescription medication for ADHD
Adderall has also developed a reputation
as a sort of Miracle pill that will make
you a gamer God who tries to get a guess
and aggressive but who attaches he's
going but who hits it it was pretty
obvious like if you listen to the calms
but there are a ton of questions
surrounding its use do Pros really use
Adderall to win tournaments are they
putting their health at risk by doing so
and most importantly does it even work
you're always looking for an edge on
somebody else they think all right I'll
give it a try you don't need it
[Music]
before we get into the video we wanted
to note that drug abuse is a serious
issue so if you or someone you know is
struggling with drugs or other issues
related to drugs there is help available
for you near where you live you can also
call the American Addiction centers
hotline at
888-985-2217 okay so people have been
trying to use performance enhancing
substances to get an edge over their
opponents for literally as long as
competitions have existed but once we as
a society came up with ways to test for
these things we really began cracking
down on that [__] whatever instances of
doping were uncovered in traditional
Sports have received considerable media
attention but Esports are a lot younger
and our drug scandals don't get talked
about very often so drugs have been a
bit of a gray area one very important
question was what even constitutes a
performance-enhancing substance in the
context of Esports Esports are primarily
mental not physical so something like
steroids would be useless and while
things like caffeine or marijuana for
example can alter your mental state it's
not like chugging a Red Bull is going to
turn you into an Esports Superstar but
in their quest to find a more Esports
friendly leg up some pros have turned to
Adderall which has long had a reputation
for off-label use as a mental stimulant
that's I think why kind of Adderall is
Big go-to because it's very explicitly a
pharmaceutical it's very explicitly
something you intake
and it has this long-storied history or
tradition of being used kind of covertly
um and without prescription for for
other Pursuits that are largely
cognitive obviously the idea that
Adderall was some sort of Esports Magic
Bullet didn't take root overnight
Whispers of Gamers using certain
substances to outdo the competition have
been going around at least as far back
as 2010 posted on forums or passed
around through Word of Mouth the issue
got a few mentions in the Press now and
again but there were just too many
stakeholders interested in keeping
things under wraps I mean I see people
say this about the Olympics too like let
people take all the drugs they want and
let's see what the true limits of human
performance are right let's see what
happens you see that all the way through
to people being like no not even
prescription drugs right so you see this
wild uh continuance of opinions like you
notice there's hush-hush attitude since
let's not talk about this it's honestly
a lot of um people who could talk about
this this could uh be hugely mental to
their careers right so this is one of
the the obstacles into kind of getting
to the bottom of this as well but in
2015 Esports fans finally learned the
truth the ESL cons were kind of funny in
my opinion
I don't even care we're all on Adderall
like well I don't even give like it was
pretty obvious like if you listen to the
calls
yeah yeah yeah yeah
people can hate it or whatever tell
everyone everyone
right yeah
so throw that up there
Revelation was a true watershed moment
for PEDs in Esports he was taking a big
risk by saying what he said on camera
because the reality is that there was
and still is a huge stigma around the
use of Adderall in competitive games
people view it as a performance enhancer
which means anyone using Adderall is
basically willfully cheating a cardinal
sin in Esports and something that could
ruin anyone's career and now the powers
that be were forced to confront an ugly
reality winners did do drugs and with
that information out in the open where
everybody could see it they were forced
to finally do something about it first
ESL partnered with nationale anti-doping
egg and tour and the world anti-doping
agency or the kind of fun to say NADA
and wada for short and made a list of
substances that were off limits for pro
players taking part in their online and
offline tournaments so what did this
drug crash down look like in practice
exactly well ESL won cologne 2015 was
the first tournament to feature what was
supposed to be drug testing tailored to
Esports authorized reps administered
random skin tests to players before
their matches but eventually swapped
over to saliva sample testing for future
events but there was a problem base
basically no one had ever put serious
anti-doping measures into place in
Esports before so no one knew what the
proper protocols were should all drugs
that kind of hinder your your psyche cut
be banned or should just they should
pick and choose now Esports can't just
half-ass it if they're going to try to
do it they have to have a full-blown
thing for it you know what I mean and
the full-blown thing wasn't too far
behind esl's first anti-doping
tournament the Esports Integrity
commission or esic was established in
2015 to make sure Pros were keeping it
clean all across the board we started
building this program by understanding
from the athletes themselves from the
players what are the substances they're
most concerned about what are the
techniques of doping that most concern
them what is it we can do to help
improve your anti-doping program because
it's about you not having to face
anybody else cheating so after all these
rules regulations and organizations were
put in place to oversee controlled
substances in Esports surely everyone
who's ever tried to dope their way to
Victory instantly flush their entire
stash over whatever and the story was
over right well no of course not in the
years it followed people began outing
themselves others and everything in
between it turns out players in every
esport allegedly used Adderall I only
took it one time and it was a very very
very small amount yeah you shouldn't be
doing this probably right like everyone
knew like you probably shouldn't be
taking massive amounts of Adderall out
of land but people were doing it and
it's I don't really care if it's legal
or it's not there just needs to be a
rule just so I know at least like what
I'm allowed to do there's probably like
20 players who use that at all or so in
the league and if if imagine if it was
illegal it was illegal to completely use
ARC was quoted saying if you are not
taking Adderall then you are putting
yourself at an intentional disadvantage
which is like
well then is everybody taking it while
efforts to curb Esports doping continued
the topic resurfaced in a big way in
2021 after Call of Duty World Champion
hook posted a tell-all describing his
struggles with Adderall use before and
during his team's 2020 Cod worlds win
you know we got the win I felt good
about that but you know those couple
days afterwards I didn't feel good and
it was mainly because of one thing
time was taking Adderall
I first took Adderall
when I was like 18 19 and um you know I
realized basically that night what it
was doing to me this is very
uncomfortable for me to talk about it
was not it wasn't doing anything good
for me and I realized that that night
because I won that event with Adderall
and just that feeling afterwards was
like
you know it wasn't that great it wasn't
that great of a feeling sempus might
have already opened this can of worms
back in 2015 but Hook's candid mission
of how the drug affected him personally
added a whole new level of Gravitas to
the issue I was playing out of anger
rather than joy that was like the
biggest realization I was like okay like
you know why I started playing the first
game was because I loved the game I
don't want to play at anger
I saw even what it was doing to my
personality over time like I was
becoming more Angry to the people I love
and
even sometimes sad and I didn't like
that now I know this has been a lot but
I'm sure that you still want the answer
to the question that we asked at the
beginning of this video can Peds make
you a better player after all Hooke did
win a world championship on Adderall and
all of these other Pros are saying the
stuff's everywhere so is this how you
get good well I could investigate that
claim myself but it's probably better if
we get the facts from somebody who
actually knows what they're talking
about there are some studies that do
show some benefits with things like
working memory or within our executive
function there are also studies that
show that it's either null or
potentially harmful and specifically for
those studies they were in healthy
populations which a lot of the times
those are the people that we care about
right because those are the people that
were working with that are interested in
hey I want to take something that might
potentially help me I'm considered
healthy I don't have this diagnosis of
ADHD
Adderall is going to make me better
currently I don't believe there's any
scientific data to support that Adderall
is a performance enhancing drug in the
context of Esports it just kind of
became this conventional wisdom that
well of course if you see these benefits
in study um and in other activities then
you'll see these benefits in Esports as
well and in case the science isn't proof
enough the players pretty much feel the
same way but I don't think it helps
everybody though like I don't think
it'll like make some like the average
player like insane for all the public
players that think that you're gonna
take Adderall you're going to take some
sort of substance and become better
become Global Elite get your articles up
you're bad and you need to get better
because no Player is taking Adderall and
instantly becoming a pro no one has ever
been average started taking Adderall and
then suddenly they're good now less
likely to choke you're probably more
likely to choke so instant God level
gaming prowess aside what specific
benefits do players look for when taking
Adderall to compete Studies have shown
that both people with ADHD and
non-affected individuals can expect to
see an improvement in their ability to
focus and pay attention to what they're
doing for extended periods of time if
they take Adderall or another stimulant
but the very same studies admit that the
actual scientific data on the subject is
limited and there is literally no major
medical research based around the Drug's
effects on Esports or gaming performance
in particular that focus and attention
thing for example doesn't really work
the way you'd expect the focus part I
guess is what people are like thinking
it makes it like when you focus that
you're going to be some smart really
smart crazy player who sees the game in
a different way I don't know didn't
really do much for me like I could focus
a little bit better in the sense that
yeah I was I was studying demos at the
time
and it helped me keep my attention on
the demo and nothing else I didn't like
side track on anything it like it felt
very very normal and the perspective is
that like oh I feel good um I feel
focused I but really nothing is like
your gameplay is not really changing
what's more the very same intended
benefits of Adderall can make you
perform worse even if you actually need
it and doubly so if you don't
essentially it's a stimulant to match
our energy levels and our mind patterns
for those of us who have it I'm not
going to go too scientific I don't I'm
not a doctor I don't know at all I said
that last week too uh but for others
it's an overdose and it puts you over
the top so it's yeah there's a
misconception there yeah I mean I feel
like in any professional setting you're
always looking for an edge on somebody
else and I think some players because
they have you know peers that do it or
colleagues that do it
they think all right I'll give it a try
you don't need it I mean I'm not the
best example because everybody questions
my level of town but guess what I got
[__] eight major championships not
one of them was one with Adderall in my
system so yeah you do not need it I kind
of proved to myself this year
that you don't need it
um this is just me I'm not gonna advise
anything but
there are healthy alternatives and there
is better ways to go about things and
there is positive ways to you know help
yourself
um and compete you know probably better
than ever so the general consensus seems
to be that it won't be Adderall or any
other performance enhancing drug that
takes your play to the next level that's
on you but then why do we even bother
with testing for or Banning something
that doesn't live up to its reputation
given everything we've just heard can we
even call Adderall a performance
enhancing drug and if not is all the
hubbub and the infrastructure around
eliminating it from Pro play Justified
we found the same that you know in our
research that there was this widespread
assumption that you know of course the
use of performance enhancers are
dominant in Esports and of course these
Esports players are using this on mass
whether or not that's true I suppose
there's also like a bias towards
assuming that people who are better than
you by magnitudes will obviously be
getting some outside help right there's
some kind of you know needing to justify
why you're not in the Pro leagues as
well they're going on so I'm sure
there's some cognitive biases that are
informing that so where does that leave
us Esports as a whole have barely even
scratched the surface when it comes to
finding out what can give some players
an unfair advantage over others but the
real issue is that we refuse to talk
about it instead we continue shaming
Pros into silence that only exacerbates
the problem lures more young players
into taking Adderall and restricts
access to those who use it as intended
and honestly we need to do a ton more
legitimate research to find out if it
even needs to be banned at all Adderall
has been the boogeyman of Esports for
years but as it turns out we might not
understand it as well as we think we do
[Music]
foreign